thank you
[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are
careful boys today we have Colleen
Kaylee
Kaylee Colleen Did you guys know that
she has the same name as Colleen
Ballinger no way
spelled the same way differently you do
so please if you if Google could
associate those two things please just
started my entire identity is also hers
and hers is mine uh you're one of the
same so you are in fact true or false
you are a director yes
true or false where are you leading me
true or false your Colleen Ballinger
this is a deposition
the blonde one in the the brunette one
she's dark energy she's light energy
yeah that's good that's good framed in
this way yeah no
um
think about the movie business right now
what's your what's your what's your
Barbie's trash oh oh you watch it get
straight to the floor did you watch it
yeah and you didn't like it no what what
don't you like about it did you see it
go oh femus in this yeah you didn't like
it because I see me huh yeah dude no it
wasn't even a thought
she's like what the [__] is that it's
just like everything because we were
talking about this a little bit um you
think it's like pure satire and they're
making fun of old Collywood I think that
they the humor didn't resonate that well
and I think it's just everything about
woke Hollywood encompassed in one so you
thought it's real [__] yeah I think they
missed a mark on the humor I think it's
too cringy for it to be like
have like a an intellectual kind of way
of doing it uh if that was too cringy to
have an actual intellectual point no
because you're not gonna get that with
Barbie I don't expect that with Barbie
um but there's a way to do a certain
satire about woke Hollywood without it
being so on the nose I don't think it
was a complete satire when I think it
was first of all I love absurdish [__]
so it was like a [__] three hour
absurdist movie I love absurdist yeah
okay so I like that part I also liked
how it it when it took itself seriously
like in a couple of moments it also
took the other side of it too and I
thought that that was interesting
um when it went girl power yay girl
power and then it went guy power [__]
yeah guy power but it's just so funny
how like the very thing is like Barbie
world has to be only women and then as
soon as the men take over it's just like
the dichotomy of like it only be one way
or in another yeah it's just I mean but
isn't that that's what we're at right
now that Barbie anyway because Barbie's
kind of like one way already like that's
what I think yeah so it's like Barbie's
all one way it's like the ocean's
plastic everyone loves Barbie it's all
one way so if the guys are gonna take
over Barbie land wouldn't it have to be
that to me well I mean the name itself
is hard to get past
Barbie land Barbie land yeah well it
became it became Kent town I don't I
think like the whole structure of the
movie was like they put a bunch of ideas
of what woke Hollywood is supposed to be
like shook it up and like just threw it
all out there
like for instance like Mattel like that
whole
um like the whole structure of Mattel
and then going to Barbie land and then
just kind of showing up and just kind of
being there like the structure of of the
humor just didn't did it for you Daddy
can I ask you an unrelated question yeah
do you hate girl power
I mean I mean how come you're sure okay
so you say you like girl power
but you don't like the Barbie movie no
yeah they're not supportive yeah right
hey dude I I support girl power did you
see Barbie no if you want to talk about
a good movie go to go to Oppenheimer
Oppenheimer openheimer who's watching
Barbie here it's just them and then they
both have the I watch Oppenheimer
do you like that one yeah I think it was
great yeah it's amazing but also I'm a
history buff so I'm biased to run up
your alley for me I was like oh
definitely yeah you know he's your
Avengers great job because I I said this
off camera too making a three hour long
movie about a bunch of men talking
that's very difficult that's so
difficult and they did such a good job
of actually piecing that together yeah
but that's why I haven't seen it yet
because nobody can [__] successfully
pitch me that oh you know what you know
what would make you watch it three hours
of dudes talking I exactly but I think
you would the reason why like if I was
to sell it to you I would be like so I
award extra points to when you have to
make a film about something that could
so easily either be bad go wrong create
outrage and they did they satisfied it
well and I think it's cool to see
somebody navigate that successfully when
you could so easily [__] it up because
this is why a three hour this is why a
three hour movie feels not so three I
think you'd be amazed because it's
actually multiple stories if you look at
it yeah so it continuously
progresses but like change is kind of
tone too because there's different
goal posts it's not like a full-on three
hours of one long it is a narrative but
like it's not you know it's like it
almost feels like one exactly like it it
opens and ends opens and ends opens and
I think the writer in you love it yeah
my brother told me there's titties in
this I'll probably see it yeah but to me
it wasn't luscious [__] yeah dude it was
like artistic tits so it's like our tits
yeah our tits is not luscious things oh
now I'll go see it but anyway thank you
I think you'd like it for that reason
like Titanic tips
it didn't feel like to me at least it
didn't feel like a pretentious three
hour movie of like watch me director
jack off on myself yeah yeah yeah it was
actually it felt like for the audience
it wasn't [__] I know what you mean
again you know like [__] the
Hollywood one what was that with Once
upon a time once upon a time was such a
oh the good old days of Hollywood and
we're [__] I get to do a movie that I
want to do it was what like how long
that movie felt like a three hour that
movie did feel long yeah I was like when
is anything gonna happen
dude same with licorice pizza that felt
way long oh really that looked like a
movie that was jerking off all over
let's watch watch that really you know
no okay if you like absurdist the Weird
Al one came out oh yeah I gotta see that
is it is like a comedy like a biopic
okay so he's starring in it it's Weird
Al right so
it's it's absurdist it's absurd and it's
like he took the it's a it's a he's a
parody genius took the piss out of the
biopics right basically he took the
format of and it gets crazy and crazy
it's like the Dewey Cox Story like which
I love I love one right right right
because that's supposed yeah yeah but I
was hoping there was some level of truth
to it because I was genuinely curious
you're interested yeah yeah but I didn't
get it I took the piss yeah yeah it was
hanging out with the queen and [__] and
like right like it may as well have been
spinal tap at that point right it just
got crazier and crazier but I I thought
it was creative how he came up with The
Inspirations of the songs in it because
like in every biopic movie about [__]
musicians it's like well I was tapping
my feet and I saw in the kitchen this
was happening and then it just came to
me you know and then like all of his
[__] things were like that for the
top hits did you see Bohemian Rhapsody
oh I love that I [__] loved it it was
the worst that way it was so good dude
oh God no Mike Myers is wrong on that
movie where he's like no but it's ever
going to listen to a band called Queen
[__] Winery it was textbook yeah I
[__] loved it but you know what I I
think like was awesome though the
performance scenes were just amazing
yeah
it could have been a music video yeah it
could just be a tick tock Stitch right
I'd also just rather watch the original
music videos too that's true true to me
it was just a transition to it was a
musical with transitions that's all it
was but
that yeah it's a weird [__] movie
what are your thoughts though on the
movie business where it's at right now
and like you know our movie's gonna die
it gets so tough I think it's tough to
be and the strikes yeah the strikes I
think it's tough to be a director to
have a something that isn't going to
quickly make money
um like with Barbie I mean whether you
think they're you know
being satire or joking or if they're
really just making a movie about that
um people are going to see it people are
gonna love it people are going to hate
it
um and people are that's what the topic
right now is about yeah and I think
that's what people are making movies now
is like whatever the topic is heavy now
so anything else that is maybe a little
bit more in depth gets a loss in
Translation funding doesn't go to it
um this uphill battle also just
everything with with sag the rider
strike I mean who knows how long that's
gonna go for they don't have a lot of
Leverage
um you know so what are you thoughts on
like the streaming aspect of it like
should people get the residuals that you
deserve yeah yeah
good answer
good answer let me zoom out a little bit
more so I just think in terms of just
overall entertainment I feel like
entertainment is usually some form of
like art slash business
and I feel like the business end has
taken priority yes over the Arts over
the art across the board I'm making so
sad because it's like everybody who
wants to create something for the art
aspect is just kind of like
like kind of depressed in a way of not
wanting to create it anymore because
there's just no incentive money-wise to
to do so yeah would you guys say like in
the film industry the biggest example of
the industry taking more of the business
side is like them pushing out all these
superhero movies
is that is that like the the model and
it works yeah because it's repeatable
they see your return on it though so
like why wouldn't they do there's almost
there's a return as soon as they green
light something right they can already
answer me how much they can get back
that's the whole thing it's like it's
more of a guarantee and you're less
likely to get fired right and then just
not on the movie side but unlike like
the uh like all the merch that comes
with like say the flash toys
um
it's more money than the movie usually
yeah for sure absolutely so yeah so if
the [__] movie doesn't do well they
still have a whole other backside of
like hey look we're we're making way
more money than we thought also hero
movies translate better overseas than
like a dialogue heavy [__] thing it's
why George Lucas wouldn't kill Han Solo
if you remember because he didn't want
he he said kids aren't going to buy a
Honda pan solo action figures if they
know he dies oh yeah wow right so true
so then that that influences writing
influences everything so I don't know
this episode is brought to you by
dragging
can you believe we've had seven months
without an NFL game crazy right well
good thing that's over and NFL is here
and drafting Sportsbook an official
sports betting partner of the NFL is
giving you a can't miss offer for week
one this week new customers can get two
hundred dollars in bonus bets instantly
when you bet just five bucks on any NFL
game DraftKings is hooking everyone up
with game day greatness all customers
can take advantage of two new offers
every single game day this September so
check the app to see what you get
download now and use the code off the
Record to sign up new customers can take
home two hundred dollars and bonus bets
instantly just for betting five bucks
that's called off the Record only on
DraftKings Sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the NFL the crown is
yours gambling problem call 1-800
Gambler or visit www 1 800 gambler.net
New York call
8778-h-o-p-e-n-y or text h-o-p-e-n-y
467-369 and Connecticut health is
available for problem gambling call
888-789-777 or visit
ccpg.org please play responsibly on
behalf of Boot Hill Casino and Resort KS
21 plus age varies by jurisdiction void
in Ontario c c d k n g dot Co slash
football for eligibility terms and
responsible gaming resources bonus bets
expire seven days after issuance
eligibility and deposit restrictions
apply I feel like
um
as we develop like more technology and
and culture move forward and stuff right
like
all this is is actually just
storytelling and we're using different
methods to tell a story like before it
was for like just in the around a
campfire then it got into like radio
then it's like opening books radio right
and then and then being able to move a
picture like a screen like you know
there's moving pictures now there's the
movie industry right so now like you can
stream real life you can do all that
stuff so as the technology moves and
people get bored because that will
happen because industry will be created
behind certain technology like the radio
there used to be radio stories and
episodes like people would tune in as a
family they just listen to that format
and then they're like well draft
attention they weren't looking at
anything else they're all listening and
looking at the radio yeah and then and
then a television came out and I and I
and I was seeing like how people were
comparing when the television
revolutionized and how that was like
YouTube because the film industry was
talking [__] saying like oh that's just
the fad TV is not you know but then
through TV they created episodic four
stories yeah deeper stories than you
could ever tell because you can be with
the same character every week right and
then there was a personal connection
like the way they feel about YouTubers
today where you're vlogging and you're
personally connected to this person
versus being at Live Theater at Broadway
or like if you watch a film and it's
just one hour right and then so like now
we're I think at this point where that
Golden Era of film that cycle is like at
this tail end where Something's Gotta
change and be disruptive attention spans
do you think that yeah I think so I feel
like this will be part of it yeah
because we're facing it on YouTube too
because during covid when Tick Tock
really blew up it took market share from
uh YouTube and long form is considered
30 minute videos now or 10 minute videos
so like I think both of them happening
at the same time though it's almost like
a new generation is coming up like I go
right like that generation is coming up
are they gonna have even shorter
attention spans and like the Millennials
have but then at the same time we have
like podcasts like Joe Rogan is three
hours do people sit there listening and
then you have streaming for like 24
hours yeah so it's like right but then
how many times do you guys sit there and
watch a movie with nothing but attention
on the movie at the theater I do that I
do that a lot because it forces you me
too I try to watch movies that's my
favorite way to watch it but then also
on the flip side too Netflix made the
binge watching possible yes right where
you would upload all seasons all at once
and now you got you know you could binge
watch whole entire series
when they don't have that I get pissed
I'm like what the [__] yeah you get mad
yeah why is it next Sunday who gives a
[__] just we grew up watching stay tuned
next Friday once a week and you're like
oh it's Sunday I can't [__] go out I
gotta watch my thing it is funny though
because I it's fun to point out the
hypocrisy of it too is it like I am part
of the problem them in the sense that
I'm complaining about mainstream films
but then I also go to Art House films go
to the theater walk out and go well that
[__] sucked yeah it's like you are still
um subject to the movie being good no
matter what medium it's on but you still
paid and support it though yeah but the
funny thing is that when something is a
mainstream like major film you have more
people policing it to make sure it's
[__] good when something's an art
house film it just has to be what it is
right and how much there's no pressure
how much stimulation right do people
need because there are people who are
right now listening to us but they're
also playing a video game or some [__]
right yeah that's tight that's tight the
best way to do it best way that we're a
routine because they want to feel
background noise or like they're getting
ready in the morning or whatever people
know these are good at that yeah yeah
people can do three things at once
especially Drive I watch JK news and
drive the whole time so people want
variety right like maybe there's
sometimes I want to zone out into
something that you know is just you know
not super intelligent and just yeah all
over the place right and then there are
times where I really want to get
involved in something I really want to
be right you know invested in in what
I'm watching right I do believe though
um you know Industries work in Cycles
right and if something becomes too
bureaucratic too much waste to in like
there's it's just too many rules and
like it has to be this format it has to
be this way you have too many kings and
queens in certain positions that never
leave their
um like place right there needs to be a
disruption that happens or else other
things will take the attention and space
of that well that disruption's happening
because the movie business is pretty
[__] right except except for like like
look at Oppenheimer and Barbie that's
like an outlier it's an outlier and
they're working really hard to replicate
Marvin Heimer like [__] hard yeah and
then it's gonna get corny but yeah
exactly they're going to work on like
the Golden Era where like remember like
when we're like kids or even in high
school the movie theater was like packed
all summer long the morning until night
yeah
most movie theaters are ghost towns
these days like you go there it's not
like people lining out the door people
getting dropped off by their parents
yeah it's like when we saw barbie we
heard how sold out it was
me and my group we were all wearing
pinkish and we're even part of the
movement uh we just bought tickets when
we got there because like yeah it wasn't
oh really everyone said it was sold out
but it wasn't dangling this [__] yeah
will you try it three times and it will
yeah and every single time it was like
all the seats were filled and I'm like I
ain't [__] waiting really that's how
I felt when I went to I whenever I go to
iPic because I watch movies there a lot
I'm like damn it sold out oh actually
there's only 16 [__] seats in there
but also there's a small theater it
depends on the culture of the city too
because I know like in Hawaii it's it's
pretty
they're more like they go out to events
they do stuff right so then like maybe
going to the movie is still a thing out
there yeah because yeah I couldn't get a
seat man I was like [__] or maybe that
immediate Community around it just does
that yeah it might be the theater that
we were going to it's just the only
thing around you know it also seems like
post covet the movie business completely
changed yeah like yeah there was like
um people were still funding like
independent projects and stuff like that
that's basically gone yeah it's really
not there unless you're some kind of
name yeah already yeah so you already
had your foot in the door but otherwise
it's really dry even in this city it's
shut down because of it yeah I started
seeing the
I don't want to say Decay but the but
the deterioration of it in about I think
2009 or 10 and when we started pitching
they were saying like the budgets were
running out for mid-tier so like they're
they're uh funding
like what do you call it Indie budgets
are under a couple mil because they're
like we could take a chance at this
because this was around the time when um
uh that [__] witch Paranormal
Activity and things like that yeah yeah
they're like they made up like 50k
exactly
a Witch Project yeah Blair Witch Blair
wish yeah yeah dude everyone wanted to
make that happen yeah so many other
stuff came out the the movie business
was like what the [__] wow genre yeah
and then and then the money was drying
up because that's around the time when a
lot of people stopped going to theaters
so then as YouTube was coming up no one
took YouTubers seriously but we're going
into these meetings and rooms because
they were curious about digital and
that's when I was like oh [__] dude this
is gonna die
and then a lot of people were like
thinking film will never like the
theaters won't ever and I'm like yeah
but they just told us that the middle
tier that they were blowing money on
like the ones were
it's kind of like mid budget right what
would they be like 10 million to 10 30.
whatever and then they're like no
everything's gonna pivot to where it's
if it's not Blockbuster top level [__]
all this stuff they're not gonna fund
and then they're gonna fund all the
small [__] to try to like get high gains
and that's exactly what they did so yeah
I mean that's the thing it's it's it was
it's all about maximizing profits at the
end as well it's a business you don't
want to get fired you don't want to get
fired and that's the biggest thing if
you have something that costs no money
but it made a huge return you're get
you're getting promoted right yeah well
it kind of goes back to what Barbara was
saying business and the art form there's
there's a lot of great stories with
great art forms that should be made that
are just getting piled and slammed
underneath and will never be made just
because they just don't have the type of
publicity or the names backing them to
do it when you look at all the movies
you watched back in the day that were
original stories that now are just being
remade rather than rather than having
another original Dude they've remade
that's someone that's
just a bunch of remakes for the most
part but it's a it's more of a guarantee
because it's got a name right so it's
got a follower yeah because then you
have a base audience that you know will
watch because I'll be like this is
stupid and I'm like but I got it but I
gotta see it
it's a Roadhouse fan base we'll see if
that pops up yeah and some people watch
it just to make sure it sucks yeah in
closing do you think that the fact that
I like the Barbie movie will get me laid
more no I think the fact that you liked
Barbie movie made me question our
friendship
well I'll watch it and I'll see if I
expect either of you up it's so weird
because I
were
funny I was just like what the [__] okay
I'm like my break I need Green's going
soft
it's so absurd it's so cringy that I I
that's what made me just I liked the
female girl power moment where uh
America what's her name Ferreira America
Ferreira was that her name oh I just
made that up picking nailed it but she
she gave a monologue about girl power
[__] and I could tell all these [__]
are getting wet about it right but then
they got
they had Ken basically you know do the
same thing almost about like being a man
and I thought that that was like oh okay
they didn't just go one way and I
thought that was it was just interesting
also additionally about like capitalism
how every time they were in that Chevy
car looked like a Chevy car commercial
it sure did like sure like they pulled
it out of a commercial and just planted
it but isn't that that's the point right
yeah yeah so but it's just like for me
I'm like is it
it's like are you sneaking in the
literalism
launching t-shirts having them unfurl
and saying what it's [__] called on
the screen yeah like it was that absurd
oh let's see if there's moments like
that where I was like okay cool but it
was always there's too little of those
moments for me to be like I believe you
oh you know what I mean so I was like
like you missed the mark too many times
for me to be like kind of like how like
Deadpool was making fun of superhero
movies the whole movie so you're like I
know yeah versus just having three
moments where they make fun of them you
just like fell into that yeah you guys
are missing the real point the real
point is Margot Robbie in a bikini come
on man Ryan Gosling with his sleeves off
that's right we've all agreed
oh